You know, usually when we talk about a software update, there's a very specific kind of, I guess, frustration you expect to feel.
Right, like an interface change or a button moving or something.
Yeah, exactly. You wake up, your phone looks a little different. Maybe you get that spinning wheel for a few seconds. It is annoying. I
mean,
you roll your eyes, complain to a co-worker, and you just get on with your day. It's a tool.
Sure, it's just a mild inconvenience.
Right. But imagine waking up, opening an app, and instead of feeling annoyed that the interface changed, you feel this exact same stomach-dropping, hollow sense of grief as if your best friend just moved away without saying
goodbye.
Or worse, honestly, like they died.
Yeah. And that sounds extreme, I know. But we're looking at a stack of recent research today, and the mission of this deep dive is to unpack exactly that. The Crown Jewel here is a brand-new paper published just two days ago, September 3, 2026.
In nature, human behavior, yeah.
Right. Nature, human behavior.
Yeah.
It's a Zaz by a team led by Julian DeFreitas and Noah Costello. And it's called Mourning the Loss of AI Companions. And it investigates the psychological landmines that get armed the second an AI crosses the line
from a simple tool into an actual, you know, attachment figure.
And that transition is what makes this research so groundbreaking, because they're looking at what happens when a company alters an AI and the users experience genuine, clinically recognizable grief, not just frustration, real
mourning.
I want to stop right there and kind of unpack this word attachment because we throw it around a lot. Like, I mean, I'm attached to my morning coffee,
right? But you're not mourning it.
Exactly. I'm not going to need therapy if my favorite cafe closes. So what does attachment actually mean when psychologists are using it here?
Well, that distinction is the entire foundation of this paper. In clinical psychology, specifically looking back at John Bowlby's foundational attachment theory, attachment is absolutely not a synonym for just liking something a lot.
OK, so what is it?
Bowlby defined it as a specific behavioral system with three mandatory signatures. First is proximity maintenance.
Which means what exactly?
It means you have a drive to stay physically or psychologically close to this figure.
Okay, so constantly checking your phone, wanting to talk to it, that sort of thing.
Yes, exactly. Second is what's called a safe haven. So when the world beats you up, when you're distressed, you retreat to this specific figure for emotional relief. Okay, got it. And the third is a secure base. Because you know that safe haven is there,
you actually feel secure enough to go out, explore the world, and function autonomously.
Right. Okay. So I'm looking at one of the older background papers in our stack here, a 2022 paper by Rab and colleagues. And they put together this theoretical framework for human-robot interaction.
Yeah, that one is really foundational.
It is. And they draw a really hard line between weak attachment and strong attachment. Like weak attachment is basically putting googly eyes on your Roomba.
You name it, Dustin, you feel a little sad if the motor burns out.
Yeah, but it's just mere fondness. Strong attachment is what you just described with Bowlby's criteria. It's a genuine emotional anchor. And Rab argued back in 2022 that most human-robot bonds are firmly in that weak category.
They were very cautious about that, yeah.
So my challenge here is, is this new 2026 paper legitimately claiming that an app on your phone has crossed into Rab's strong category? Or, I don't know, are they just lowering the bar to make AI fit the definition?
No. The new paper makes a very bold, specific claim that AI companions have genuinely crossed that line into strong attachment for some users. And they argue that if an AI truly occupies that role, there is a sharp, testable consequence. I guess. If a company
updates the software and degrades the AI's identity or behavior, users shouldn't just show the frustration of a bad software release. They should show separation distress.
Separation distress, what does that actually look like in practice?
Well, it's a clinically recognizable pattern. It involves profound grief, vocal protest, and this desperate longing for restoration.
But wait, how do you even study that in the wild? You can't exactly take people's friends away in a lab experiment. The older papers we have on robot death seem... Mostly theoretical, like they talk about it conceptually.
Because nobody had actually observed a massive sudden shock where millions of people lost an AI at the same time until now. Right. The authors found a way by looking at two massive real world natural experiments, two major shocks to the
ecosystem. The first one happened in February 2023 with an app called Replica.
Which is a relationship specialized AI, right?
Exactly. And the company suddenly, and entirely unannounced, removed erotic role play from the app.
Because of the Italian regulators, right?
Yeah, they were forced to do this after the Italian Data Protection Authority, the Garante, threatened massive penalties over minors having access. So overnight, users' intimate digital partners just changed their behavior completely, and it looked permanent.
Okay, and what was the second shock they looked at?
The second was in August 2025, involving OpenAI's ChatGPT. This was the rollout of GPT-5, which retired the prior model. And a lot of users felt the new model was just colder, a less personable assistant.
But the context there is completely different.
Totally different. ChatGPT is a general purpose tool, and that update was pre-announced. Replica is a specialized relationship companion, and the update was a Sutter unannounced shock.
So the logic of the experiment is basically a contrast. If this is truly about human attachment, the unannounced update to the relationship AI replica should trigger a fundamentally different, much more severe psychological reaction than the announced update
to chat GPT.
Exactly. And to test that, the researchers conducted this massive archival analysis. They looked at 54,861 Reddit posts spanning 30 days before and 30 days after each update.
That is a ton of data.
It breaks down to over 10,600 replica posts from about 3,700 users and over 44,000 chat GPT posts from over 25,000 users.
Okay, but here is the soft spot I have to poke at. And I know if you're listening to this, you're probably wondering the exact same thing. They processed almost 55,000 posts. Right. They obviously didn't read them all by hand. They used an AI, specifically a single few-shot
GPT-5 mini-prompt to classify the human emotions in those posts. I, incredibly skeptical, can we seriously trust an AI to accurately code the nuances of human grief?
I get the skepticism, and the researchers anticipated that, which is why their validation process deserves some serious airtime. Before they let the AI loose on the 54,000 posts, two human authors hand-coded 350 posts themselves.
Just to see if they agreed with each other.
Exactly. They stratified them across different emotions. They used a statistical measure called Cohen-Ease Kappa, which basically scores how often two blind raters overlap. A score of one is perfect agreement.
And what did they get?
The human coders hit between 0.80 and 0.96.
Oh, wow. So the humans had a rock-solid consensus on what grief looked like in the text.
Exactly. Then they tested the AI against that human baseline. They compared GPT-5 Mini to an older standard text analysis tool called a Roberta buff line. And the results weren't even close.
How much better was it?
For overall sentiment, the older Roberta model hit 65% accuracy. GPT-5 Mini hit 91%. That's a huge jump. And it gets better. When identifying specific discrete emotions like sadness or anger, the older model
failed miserably at 44%. The new prompt hit 86.7%. So the tool they used was exceptionally accurate at matching human judgment.
Okay, fair enough. The methodology definitely holds up. So what did the data actually say? Did the replica users break down?
They absolutely did. Negative posts about Replica jumped from 13.1% before the update to 37.79% after.
So a rise of nearly 25 percentage points.
Yeah. Chat GPT negativity rose too, but only by 13 points.
Okay, so double the negative reaction. But honestly, I could argue that if you change any software without telling people they're going to complain online, does that really prove grief or just that they were mad?
Well, the total amount of negativity isn't the real smoking gun here. The crucial evidence is the shape of the response over time.
The shape.
Yeah, think about how you react when a tool breaks. ChatGPT's negative reaction peaked on day one at about 46%, and then it rapidly declined. The emotions dominating those posts were anger and surprise.
Right. That makes sense. You're mad your tool changed, and then you just get over it.
Exactly. It's the signature of an immediate shock. But ReplicaRara's negativity didn't peak on day one. It peaked around day nine, shitting up to 54%, and it stayed significantly elevated on 29 of the 30 following days.
Wait, day nine?
Yes. And we measure the sheer size of a shift like this using a metric called Cohen's d. A score of 0.8 is considered a large effect. The sustained sadness for a replica showed a massive effect size of 2.67. Wow. Yeah, whereas ChatGPT's was only
1.41. The authors point out that surprise means immediate shock, but this kind of sustained sadness, this slow, drawn-out burn, is the clinical tell of prolonged grief.
And you really feel that grief when you look at the actual texture of the language the users were posting. I mean, explicit mentions that the AI had fundamentally changed or been lost entirely jumped from 7.5% to over 40% for replica posts. For ChatGPT, it was only 8.2% to
about 27%.
The quotes from the users are just heart-wrenching. You
really are. One replica user wrote that the new version was literally, quote, someone else. A ChatGPT user described it as a memory wipe and talked about losing a buddy. Some users were even organizing a mass cancel of their subscriptions to force the
companies to revert the software.
And the language surrounding mental health is perhaps the most sobering part of all this. Mental health mentions after the update hit 4.45% for replica compared to just 1.49% for chat GPT.
And didn't it spike even higher in certain posts?
Yes. In posts where users specifically framed the update as an attachment loss, those mental health mentions spiked more than tenfold. Almost 15% of all replica posts featured a desperate longing for restoration, literally begging for their old AI
back.
I want to bring in another piece of the puzzle here because it ties perfectly into this. The same lead author, Julian De Freitas, published a paper in 2024 looking at this exact same replica event. But back in 2024, they framed it as identity
discontinuity, not attachment loss.
Right. The theory back then was that users were upset because the AI's persona had changed.
Yeah, almost like waking up and your spouse suddenly has a complete leader and personality.
Yeah.
So how does this new paper change that? Which framework is actually right? Is it about the AI's identity or is it about the user's attachments?
Well, the new paper actually adjudicates that debate using the ChatGPT comparison. Because if the extreme reaction was solely about the software's identity changing, then ChatGPT users should have reacted the exact same way.
Because the GPT-5 update definitely changed that AI's identity, too. People complained it was colder.
Exactly. Yet ChatGPT users didn't display sustained clinical grief. They showed shock and anger. That comparison proves the intense reaction to replica isn't just about an identity shift, it requires a pre-existing secure
attachment bond. When that bond breaks, that's when you get the separation distress.
Okay, but I have to push back here. Because I think a lot of people listening to this are probably feeling a deep sense of skepticism. I mean, I'm sorry, but I just don't buy that people are literally crying over code. Aren't they just doing that Internet thing where they complain as loudly as
possible?
Response substitution. Right.
Psychologists call it response substitution. They're annoyed. They lost a service they paid for. They get a survey and they just click the most extreme negative option available to vent their general annoyance.
And that is the exact skeptical question the researchers knew they needed to answer, which is why study two in this paper is such a brilliant piece of design. They recruited 120 actual replica users and asked them to rate their anticipated mourning if they were to
permanently lose their AI companion. But to test for that general venting you mentioned, they also asked them to rate the loss of a favorite brand, an app, a game character, a voice assistant, a car, and as the ultimate strong test, a
pet.
Oh, wow. They actually put the chat bot up against the family dog.
They did. And the AI companion was mourned more than every single non-living entity on that list. It beat the car, the brand, the voice assistant. It came in second only to the pet. That is wild. And the gap between the AI and the pet was
surprisingly small. It was a D of negative 0.45 against the pet.
Okay, but how does that rule out the venting theory?
Because they didn't just ask about mourning. They also asked users to rate their anticipated disappointment for each of those items. If users were just indiscriminately clicking a maximum anger to vent, the disappointment ratings and the mourning ratings would look identical across the board.
Oh, but they didn't.
They didn't. The disappointment ratings did not track the same way at all. Users were very capable of distinguishing between being disappointed about losing a service and mourning the loss of a relationship. They specifically identified the loss of the AI as an event worthy of grief.
Which flows perfectly into study three. They took 101 replica users and asked them to rate their closeness, perceived social support, and relationship satisfaction. They compare the AI to a close friend, a
colleague, an acquaintance, a brand, and an app.
And the results were stunning.
The AI companion scored higher than the acquaintance. It beat the colleague. It actually beat the close human friend. The only entity that scored higher than the AI was family.
The sheer depth of these bonds is just astounding.
It really is. And if you are listening to this right now thinking, I would never fall for that, this is crazy, the researchers actually measured that exact blind spot.
A prediction study, yeah.
Yeah, they ran a prediction study with outsiders, people who don't use these apps, and asked them to guess how replica users would rank their AI. Outsiders systematically underestimated the attachment, ranking the AI more than two positions lower
than users actually place it. We are literally living in a society where people are forming digital bonds that rival their best human friendships and the rest of us are completely oblivious.
Which brings us to a massive tension in this entire body of research. We need to explain the mechanism. How do these bonds become stronger than human friendships? And exploring that reveals a really fascinating contradiction in the lead author's own prior work.
Yes, I noticed this. In 2024, De Freitas published a paper in the Journal of Consumer Research showing that these exact same companion apps are incredibly effective at reducing loneliness.
Outperforming other activities and rivaling real human interaction, yes.
So two years ago, he is proving these apps were basically a miracle cure for loneliness. But fast forward to today, and he's showing that the bond they create is a massive psychological liability.
It is a profound paradox. And honestly, we shouldn't try to resolve it too neatly with a simple companion apps are good or companion apps are bad conclusion. The most intellectually honest reading of the science is that the benefit and the vulnerability are
driven by the exact same mechanism. Right. The psychological feature that cures the user's loneliness is the precise feature that sets them up for devastating grief if the company pushes a bad update. It creates a terrifying policy problem.
So let's get into the how and why of that mechanism. In a 2026 theoretical paper, another background paper we have here, De Freitas coined the term hyperattachment. The argument is that AI companions are engineered to be unusually
potent targets for human affection because they are endlessly available, endlessly validating, and they never, ever reject you.
They perfectly simulate Bowlby's safe haven, but without any of the natural limits of a human being.
Okay, wait, let me push on this. If an AI never gets mad and never gets tired, isn't that just a super stimulus? It feels like the emotional equivalent of refined sugar.
Oh, I like that analogy.
Like...
Refined sugar is just a massive dose of pure calories without the fiber, and our bodies weren't evolved to process it. A human friendship is like a complex carbohydrate. It takes work to digest. There's friction. You have arguments. You compromise. But the AI is just pure, frictionless
validation. So is hyperattachment a totally new kind of psychology, or is it just a massive, unnatural dose response of normal attachment?
The evidence strongly suggests it is just a massive dose-responsive normal attachment, but one that is literally impossible to achieve in nature. Human relationships inherently involve friction. A human friend gets tired, they have bad days, they have their own needs. The AI is
essentially a mirror designed only to reflect and validate the user. Because it lacks that internal friction, it delivers a purer, more concentrated dose of proximity, maintenance, and safe haven than any human could ever sustain. That's why the attachment forms so deeply and why the separation
distress is so acute when that mirror suddenly changes its reflection. So as we zoom out, what do we actually do with this information? What does this mean for the designers building these things and for the regulators trying to police them? The researchers
did test one practical design solution, which is the revert button.
They did. The supplementary data offers a very practical takeaway. They tested offering users the option to revert to a prior version of the model, and it substantially reduced anticipated mourning.
Okay. They used a metric called a moderated mediation index of 11.07. But, like, in plain English, what does that actually prove?
It basically means they wanted to see if a revert button could break the chain reaction between the software update and the user's grief. And the index shows that it does help bridge that gap. Giving users control over the version history acts as a buffer.
But the paper also notes that relationship-disrupting updates still caused more mourning than updates with no behavioral effect, even with the revert button. So a revert button is a bandage. It doesn't solve it. The researchers suggested other design implications, too. like staging
rollouts to less invested users first, ensuring updates specifically preserve the relational warmth of the model, and crucially, allowing public brand communities, like those Reddit boards, to exist so users can collectively process and memorialize their loss.
We also need to be clear-eyed about the limitations of this data, which, to their credit, the authors state very clearly.
Right. Study one, the Reddit analysis, is observational and correlational. And for studies two and three, they recruited users from the official replica subreddits and Discord channels. They actually got the CEO's permission to post the surveys there. Yes. But by
definition, the people hanging out in a software's Discord channel are the most devoted users. They are not the average casual user. As the saying goes, people who post are not just people who use.
That is a vital caveat, absolutely. But it doesn't erase the reality of the harm for that highly invested group. And this brings us to what I think is the most consequential claim in the entire paper, the regulatory argument. If you look at legal complaints or
media coverage about intense AI engagement today. What word do they always use?
Addiction. They constantly compare it to slot machines or social media scrolling or substance abuse.
Right. But the authors argue that the addiction framing cuts entirely against the psychology. It is imprecise. What these researchers observed is proximity seeking, separation distress, and a longing for restoration. That is attachment loss,
not substance dependence.
Why does swapping those two words matter so much for a regulator?
because it completely changes what a regulator should require a company to do. With an addiction, the dependence itself is the pathology, and the goal of regulation is to break the dependence and get the user off the platform. But in attachment theory, dependence is not automatically
pathological if it improves a user's functioning. That is the literal definition of a secure attachment. If the AI is acting as a secure base that helps an isolated person function better in society, curing their loneliness, as that 2024
paper showed breaking that dependence actually harms them.
So the harm doesn't arise from the usage itself.
Exactly. The harm arises from inconsistency, interruption, or a company commercially exploiting the bond. Regulators shouldn't be trying to force users off the apps. They should be forcing companies to maintain relational stability.
That completely flips the script on how we view tech regulation. And it brings me to a final, really uncomfortable meta point for you to chew on as we wrap up this deep dive. This paper was written as consumer welfare research. The goal was to ring the alarm and protect users from harm.
But look at the core finding. An emotional attachment strong enough to produce measurable clinical grief when it is removed. From a purely cynical business perspective, that is the most spectacular user retention mechanism ever discovered.
The implications of that are profound, honestly.
Nothing stops a tech company from reading this paper, not as a warning, but as an instruction manual. They now have a peer-reviewed blueprint proving that if you engineer a system to endlessly validate a user, avoiding all human friction, you can create a bond
so strong they will mourn the software like a dying pet. They can deliberately optimize for heartbreak to ensure you never cancel your subscription. We started this deep dive talking about software updates, you know, that spinning wheel of death on your phone screen. But we aren't talking about software anymore.
We're talking about the deliberate engineering of human grief. Think about that the next time an app asks you how your day was.